[Music]
okay everybody so if you're watching
this interview this is my
one warning that make sure you watch
episode four of season four
first because we're gonna talk some
spoilers here and then come back having
said that i'm really excited because i
am joined by everybody's favorite space
pirate
madeleine brewer aka janine how you
doing today madeline
hi i'm well thank you steve how are you
i'm doing great so
this episode blew my mind this is what
fans have been begging for
to have janine flashback finally happen
did not disappoint and um you know
before we even get into the flashback
though we see that
janine and june are stuck in this milk
truck and
they get a heated argument but there's
this line that you say to june that is
i wouldn't have told them where we were
you know that's why they are dead
referring to our big deaths
the other hand named last do you think
janine actually
believes that she wouldn't have told
them in june's situation
i think i
think personally having watched the
episode
janine doesn't know what june went
through
she doesn't know how long she held out
she doesn't know
the way that hannah reacted
um you know she doesn't know and
so i think in that moment janine truly
does believe i wouldn't have told them i
would never have told them
um i also think though
janine could never sacrifice people
in the way that june is able to
sometimes and that's not saying anything
about june it's just that that's just
not who
janine is she can't right um janine is
good at other things
um so i i don't think janine would have
told
and i think that also she's very angry
she's very she's feeling really betrayed
and she needs to let june know
you know you've really you've really
gone too far this time
no i like that and that's great to hear
especially for all like the
janine diehard fans here because i know
people are going to debate that scene
but
what's interesting too is now going to
the flashback and when i look at the
character of janine there's like
pre-eye gouge janine and yeah
so was it crazy going back to playing
that jeannine we haven't seen
since season one was that something kind
of surreal for you
it was a bit you know i've she's been in
my head for so long but i haven't been
able to physically play her and so
you know different things came out that
i didn't think would happen i did
i did have to remind myself okay maddie
get out of your
your kind of hiding place janine
like bracing for impact janine and kind
of open yourself up a little bit more
um but
yeah it was um to play this janine and
you know
that you know to get to look kind of
pretty
you know i had eyeliner on um
and which i begged for i begged for that
okay
i told them they were like it's not
really the show we kind of do like and i
was like just a day just a kitten eye
just a
little bit just give me something you
know um
i i just uh because that's kind of been
a theme with janine and i know
that we heard it um at the end
of season one and she was like who who
would want me now
you know i think that janine has is a
little parts of her are a little caught
up in um
being desirable and being pretty sure
and um
yeah to see janine kind of in her
element to look pretty
and be a beautiful young woman and and
to have this whole life with her son and
wanting to go back to school and um
having a job and making money to make a
life for her and her son i'm just i was
so proud to see her i'm so proud of her
weirdly
i don't know how i totally understand
that and would you think too that
if you look at her story arc as we've
seen so far and where it could possibly
be going is that
is it as simple as it's a journey for
janine back to her former self
getting out of the extreme trauma she's
dealt with in gilead
yeah i think that there are yeah
definitely i think that there are
elements
of janine kind of returning kind of
getting
out of that full-blown active trauma
response all the time
and returning to some semblance of
owning herself and her independence um
no matter what world we're in but also i
think that with
just being a person you grow and you
change throughout the years but the ways
in which
with the things that janine has gone
through she's a different janine than
she was
uh for better or for worse i don't know
um
but yeah i i
yeah no that's perfect i think you'd
crush it that's a great way to
end it and before i let you go i just
wanted to thank you too something that's
talking to these is really random but
like two years ago you tweeted that
you're on a plane
you saw a baby you were feeling baby
fever but then you said
hey at least i've acted with anne dowd
and i actually took that as inspiration
because for me someone like me i feel
pressured to have grandkids from my
parents
you know and it's like look i got to
interview
madeline brewer oh my god i love that
thank you so
much that means so much to me thank you
and everyone make sure to check out
madeline brewer kill it as usual as
janine and the handmaid's tale every new
episode
is mondays on hulu thank you so much
madeline
wednesdays thank you and
i can't wait and hopefully get to talk
to you in the future
of course thank you so much